does the inability of the average person
to defend themselves make them more
susceptible to fear generally in life
and can jiu-jitsu present jiu-jitsu
reduce societal fear I think is it a
pretty obvious answer but yeah I mean
obviously if you can defend yourself
it's gonna give you more confidence in
the world and if you don't know how to
dissent defend yourself you're gonna
have more fear in the world that's just
the way it is and I know that jiu-jitsu
definitely gave me a lot of confidence
in the world because when you're looking
at someone you you at least know you're
not a pushover at a minimum you know I'm
not gonna go out easily so yeah I think
if you don't know how to defend yourself
at all I think you're definitely gonna
be more susceptible to fear that's kind
of common sense and also the the thing
with not knowing when you don't know
about things you you are more scared of
them human confrontations cuz you're on
them on the Jitsu mat you're in
confrontations all the time and if you
do in a case you know occasionally you
should put on boxing gloves and box and
even strike during jujitsu you should do
that stuff so you recognize what it's
like to be in a fight and then you have
you'll be less afraid of the unknown cuz
it's known we're always afraid of the
unknown well now this is known now the
other thing is the better you are with
jujitsu and the better you are at
fighting the less apt they're less
likely you are to have to use it because
because people will know that you by the
way you're acting that you're probably
not person that should be messed with
and the other thing is I think when
people actually know how to fight they
put up less of a front about who they
are about trying to act like a tough guy
because hey man
I'm feeling pretty good you know I got a
problem saying hi to you I mean I can I
can say hi to you in the street like hey
how's it going no big deal I'm not
feeling like you're gonna take advantage
of me now cuz I know how to fight so a
lot of jiu-jitsu guys are super nice
guys you know because they're not trying
to prove how tough they are cuz you
actually know how tough they are
so I think that's pretty obvious you
know that's the the many benefits of
jiu-jitsu from a personal level then as
far as societal fear I would also say
yes it's it's helpful because if you can
handle yourself on a personal level
right then you can handle yourself in
other dynamic situations and you're more
aware of things and you are better at
staying calm right dude it to teach you
how to stay calm oh yeah you getting a
bad situation if you panic you're going
down so and you get input bad situations
all the time so you get used to it you
realize that you need to detach and you
need to get out of your head and can't
panic and can't get claustrophobic you
used to get claustrophobic and you don't
really get cost Republic too much
anymore allegedly straight up and and
also with jiu-jitsu and you know mixed
martial arts training boxing Muay Thai
wrestling you overcome adversity you
know you overcome adversity you have to
and so when you know how to overcome
adversity on the mat or in the cage or
in the ring that's gonna help you in
real life overcome adversity so I think
that those are real simple reasons why
this is good if you didn't think I
thought you just as good I do think it's
good something is good for good for
everyone and really there's a lot of
martial arts you could put in there I'm
talking about jiu-jitsu but it's the
same with boxing it's the same with with
Muay Thai it's the same with wrestling
it's the same with judo sometimes I
forget to mention judo I shouldn't judo
is also very effective martial art so I
think all those things are very helpful
for personal overcoming personal fear
and giving people confidence and they're
thereby overcoming societal fears as
well yeah is it this kind of a sign out
with with the G with Jiu Jitsu force
let's say and this more applies to this
concept kind of has been coming up
recently where you know your first day
in jujitsu where you I think you and me
and kind of our time where we started
you just - we didn't look at it in terms
of like playing God I didn't you know
you started digit 2 in 1992 I'm just
saying
from 92 all the way to about I don't
know I don't know the date but I'm
saying if you like old-school jujitsu
where you probably started YouTube
because of heights Gracie if you're one
of these people one of us that's why I
started boys Gracie won UFC 104 we
looked at jiu-jitsu as okay if I get in
a fight with someone I want to be able
to win the fight even if he's bigger
than me it wasn't because I want to be
the next world champion you know
concerned about how to effectively hold
you know the most points are points in
this yeah or when I pull guard like the
coolest like flip move I can do or
whatever and I'm not saying like that's
what it is and I'm not saying that but
there that is in the game now so
sometime as a result of this sometimes
you can go with no jiu-jitsu experience
you don't know about choice Gracie
necessarily you haven't you know that
isn't what compelled you did you learn
jujitsu you just hear great things like
you know from chaco or whoever and
you're like hey I want to go learn
jujitsu this is the best fighting thing
according stuck I'm gonna go see I'm
gonna go see what up and then they go in
there and then let's say the first day
they'll learn you know just an armlock
from the bottom or you know something
that if you don't go in with the full
context of what jiu-jitsu is it won't
translate you know you'll learn a move
and you'll be like wait how am I gonna
go in a fight now you know it's like
cool that's a cool move it's kind of
like you know that hey let me show you
when your kid let me show you this
finger lock you're like that's cool but
how are you gonna get my finger exactly
you know like all this day just doesn't
apply to a fight so so just to answer
I just did a little like tiny
instructional thing for some people that
hadn't trained before and it was support
a charity and so it's all good but you
know these people never done judges
before and I taught them you know the
mountain escape right and immediately
you know one of the guys hey you know
what happens when they do this because
he's doing this right here okay so bring
it back in everyone it and basically you
know after this happened a couple times
I said here's the deal I'm teaching you
a new language yeah so far I've taught
you the word the right that's the only
word I've taught you the yeah I haven't
even taught you I because that would
that would be a context of self
awareness which you don't have
you only know the that's it that's it
that's all you know and actually I
should have you guys should have said I
just taught you the word purple yeah
because you can't LA actually can apply
to different this when you just learn
one thing it's it's not meaningless but
it's only it's almost if you walk into a
foreign country and the only word you
knew how to say was purple in their
language it's not gonna get you very far
at all
right it's not know and that's the same
thing so you're right in the context of
like a singular move jiu-jitsu is
worthless right now when I learned five
moves and knew the rear naked choke the
arm walk the Chimaera and no one else
knew anything when you can say five
different words in a world where no one
can speak yeah you have power then
that's the way it used to be now it's
not like that anymore
everybody everybody watches UFC every
watches UFC and so they everyone's seen
an armlock before everyone's seen a rear
naked choke thing you can watch a you
rear naked choke and see that's a simple
move you can see how you put that on
somebody mm-hmm so yes you are correct
but if you got it you got to do more
than just the context of like a singular
move because that's gonna be very useful
to you yeah so when you all right I
remember watching UFC and there was a
guy who would commentate right kind of a
nerdy guy but he he kind of knew
apparently he took jujitsu so he would
kind of call it he'd be like okay so now
it's Gracie he wants to get on top right
now stops his position he can't get the
takedown so now he's pulling guard kind
of thing and then or he'll be like okay
he's establishing position with a mount
and he's gonna he's gonna punch him
until he turns over and then he's gonna
choke him and he's calling it and he
does it right so I remember thinking
okay that mount position very it's very
powerful or if he's on the bottom you
want guard kind of thing he can see you
know cuz he can't explain so when I
first started jujitsu like an actual
class I knew what guard was I knew what
mount was I knew those positions and why
they're important where you know like if
you're if someone's mounted on you where
voice Gracie would always be mounted on
the person it's like it's really hard to
get out he's gonna struggle and and if
you turn over you're even worse
situation you know so I kind of knew
that so I knew the actual context and a
lot of people when they go in jujitsu
just because they
here about how cool it is they don't
have that that that foundation going in
so I think man I think that I don't know
if they'd ask for it or what but I think
when when instructors when a new person
a brand new person don't know zero days
ago due to if they teach that like this
is the mount this is why it's important
you know just like how you did at the
muster where you know yeah I can you
know I can hit you you can hit just like
that and then that'll provide content
and then at the end how you taught a
move you know a submission or whatever
then it's like okay in mount this is one
of the many things you can do and this
icon and by the way when I say many I
mean infinite yes yeah so yeah I think
that if you and I guess this goes out to
like anyone who goes into their
jiu-jitsu class and learned it just
happened to be on the day where you
learn like some kind of arbitrary move
given the fact that you don't know the
foundation it with the foundation any
move is gonna make a lot more sense as
long as you have that foundation the
important somehow importance of guard
there worked in some you know all these
other things now of course we all want
to learn the submission what school
submission what can I get this guy in
who wants to fight me this guy yeah
another thing that people asked is you
know well there he keeps pulling my hand
away I go yeah it's a fight you're
fighting another person it's not just
who's not magic
I saved you dude's is magic but it's not
magic it's not magic it's actually it's
a white the person's gonna resist you
have to have moves yeah I didn't it
doesn't turn into magic until you have
it all together yeah then it turns into
magic and then you bestow it upon
someone who doesn't know this little guy
George he's a purple belt I was white
belt and man he's he's the one who
taught me butterfly guard he was small
too and he would flying me around doing
butterfly guard sweeps and like straight
arm locks and stuff like from the bottom
they're like bro what is this guy do
magic yeah and one time he's like
someone out while we're you know how
like when you're rolling you can kind of
talk to people while you're rolling you
know especially if you're rolling with a
guy who's advanced as well because you
don't have to focus on what you're doing
kind of thing
so this was an introduction of that
concept where I'm rolling with George
he's carrying on a conversation this guy
inappropriate like it wasn't that it was
someone was asking him like hey like how
do you how did you do that kind of thing
he
like well this is what he's doing and
while we're rolling he's kind of
commentating his rolling and he's like
so and this sets up the sweep which I'm
about to get him within it yeah and he
gets me with the sweep and that's a
small that's why it is that's why it is
kind of magic magic because like when if
I could make this coin disappear
if I could actually do that that would
be magic if I can take your arm against
your will and straighten it out and
there's nothing you can do to stop it
yeah it's kind of magic too yeah I mean
that is what magic is the right one when
you make make it appear it's like
illusion right were you a milling about
I'm talking about actual yeah actual
magic yeah yes they don't know when they
don't know how you did that so it's
similar to that making the coin
disappear but it really just went behind
yeah knuckle or whatever impossible oh
wait you like duty-bound Gail let me see
how you did that yeah watch this do it
again do it again
I still don't got it do it it to me get
it to you